okay I'm having a really bad
like sensory processing day
so let's get ready for a day at home with the kids
where I feel like I don't wanna crawl out of my own skin
I just got home from the gym
and this is what I was wearing
I could wear this but then I feel yucky
so I'm gonna go take a shower
and then we're gonna get changed
okay I put on this cute
comfy set I actually have this in three colors
I love it because it's loose
but it's very cute and once I add some accessories
you can totally run errands in this
I've done that before I also have some fuzzy socks on
so I'm gonna add it's really cold today
so I'm gonna add oh shoot
I should do my makeup first
I'm gonna do my makeup first
and yes
I will still do makeup on a day that I feel like shit
because it just makes me feel better
um but I'm gonna do like
a light coverage like a CC cream
and just kind of do this with my hands
like aggressively
almost run out of this this is the Fenty Beauty matchstick
which I really like so do a little bit up there
they're not really into see it cause of the hat
a little concealer I always use Too Faced
but just like
a tiny bit just to cover dark circles in
a little blemish here but not full beat
a little goes a long way with this product too
you don't wanna overdo it
same thing goes for these liquid blushes from Rare Beauty
they a little tiny dot goes a long way
but I really love this color
this is uh
it's called hope ah
we could all use some of that
I'm do a little bit of a wing because it's just my thing
alright hats back on
and then it's amazing what like
a pop of a lip color can do to make people think you've got your shit together
surely she can't be having a mental breakdown
she has red lipstick on now
to serve a little extra count today
I'm gonna add on this absolutely gorgeous necklace
that I got for my birthday this year
stunning right
it's my first piece of like
maybe not my first piece
but that's one of the first pieces of real big girl jewelry that I bought myself
which
I was very proud of although I do usually need my husband help me get it on
there we go isn't it just stunning
it's that ombre Topaz I love it
so yeah
now I feel cozy and comfortable
but I could still leave if I needed to run errands and
getting ready does make me feel better motherfucker